as chair and labor secretary
as well as chair and labor secretary
walsh as vice chair released publicly
the report is delivered to president
biden that includes nearly 70
recommendations to promote worker
organizing and collective bargaining the
recommendations include ways to increase
private sector workers access to
information about their existing right
to join organize a union a hugely
important issue for the president the
president accepted the recommendations
and as a follow-up the task force will
submit a second report to the president
in six months which will describe
progress and implementation and contain
additional proposals for further action
i also wanted to note that today the
secretary secretary of agriculture tom
vilsack will be announcing that the
partnerships for climate smart
connection commodities program in which
the department of agriculture will
invest one billion dollars in
partnerships to support america's
climate smart farmers ranchers and
forest land owners these funds will go
to projects that promote farming
ranching and forestry practices that
either remove carbon from the atmosphere
or cut greenhouse gas emissions the
investment is the latest biden
administration initiative aimed at
combating climate change with a goal to
cut the farm sector's greenhouse gas
emissions in half by 2030 and put the
united states on a path to net zero
emissions by 2050. finally one to note i
have a team usa water bottle out here
today and a team usa pin out here today
uh as you all know we made a decision
the united states not to send a
diplomatic deal or official delegation
to beijing given the prc's ongoing
genocide and crimes against humanity and
xinjiang and other human rights abuses
and that was a clear statement and a
clear policy made by our government but
at the same time we wanted to note team
usa has our full support we're behind
them we're watching from home uh we want
to thank them and their families for
everything they have sacrificed over the
course of time uh lots of athletes to
watch i'll just give a plug
because i'm an olympics obsessed person
nathan chen we're going to watch him
chloe kim michaela schifrin you've got
lots more chances anyway we'll be
rooting for u.s athletes even as we made
a very important statement about
our concerns about beijing's and the
chinese uh human rights abuses with that
um let's go ahead colleen kick us off
okay so um regarding dr lander um i
wondered if he should have been
reprimanded more strongly given the
president's
pledge oxford state office to you know
fire anybody who mistreated their
employees
well let me just give you an overview of
what we have done to date and i know
there may be more questions on this of
course which we welcome uh the president
has been crystal clear uh with all of us
about his ex high expectations of how he
and his staff uh should be creating a
respectful work environment one of the
steps we took early on in the
administration was to institute a safe
and respectful workplace policy across
the executive office of the president
something that was done early on it was
because of this policy in this process
that when these when the complaint was
filed a full and thorough investigation
was conducted pursuant to that policy in
addition following the conclusion of the
thorough investigation into these
actions senior white house officials
conveyed directly to dr lander that his
behavior was inappropriate and the
corrective actions that were needed
which were which the white house will
monitor for compliance moving forward
i'd also note that dr olander also sent
a message to
his staff outlining some of the steps
he's intending to take to build a
respectful work environment and
certainly we would encourage those and
again uh the team the senior team will
be watching for compliance to these
steps it looks like he's had a history
of you know possible mistreatment of his
employees
period of time how can you be sure that
this reprimand will uh stick
well well i would i would just reiterate
again that uh well let me start with the
first part of your question um each
nominee undergoes a thorough vetting
process as a part of their nomination
and confirmation process and of course
we look carefully to ensure each
candidate suitability for the role
they're chosen for dr
lander's record was thoroughly examined
as a part of his confirmation and he
received bipartisan support including
final confirmation with a voice vote but
again once we were made aware of the
complaint we launched a thorough
investigation and compliance with the
recommendations uh is will be uh will be
required in this regard
so i think that on ukraine
office said yesterday that a diplomatic
solution
seems much more likely than war and then
we saw jake sullivan say yesterday that
an invasion could come at any day
can you help us where the difference
here and why there still seems to be
such a dark assessment a stark
difference in assessing
the threat well what our national
security advisor also conveyed during
some interviews with a range of your
networks yesterday was that we're
pursuing a two-track approach which
includes deterrence and diplomacy uh but
that we are ready either way for
whatever decision president putin might
make and we don't have a new assessment
of uh of his decision and where he
stands on it uh we also need to be
prepared being prepared is exactly what
we can do uh from the us government in
coordination and in partnership with our
nato allies our partners in eastern
europe and of course the ukrainians and
that is what we're focused on so we
don't actually see it as a conflict
is kiev wrong
in terms of uh the preparations or
dramatic solution being more likely than
war it seems hard to score that with
sullivan saying that an invasion could
come in any day well i think we
certainly would prefer a diplomatic
solution i think that's everybody's
preference and everybody's hope
but again this is up to remains up to
president putin to make a decision about
which path he's going to take we don't
have
an assessment of that so what our focus
is on is preparing for a range of
contingencies including in coordination
with ukrainians making sure they have
the supplies they need the humanitarian
assistance they need the security
assistance they need and we're doing
that uh we're doing that consistently
even while we are closely watching uh
the build-up of troops on the border
switch topics if i may uh delta ceo is
asking for the administration's help in
creating this no-fly list for unruly
passengers is that something the
administration supports talk to our team
about that i can see if there's any uh
opinion on that from here okay quickly
uh housekeeping do you have a sense of
when the president will start meeting
with scotus candidates and if any of
these meetings happen
in delaware where the president where
there are not visitor logs does the
white house pledge to disclose that
those meetings took place
well i think at this point i don't have
any more details about the process to
outline for you as you know
what the president's been focused on
over the course of the last several days
is
reviewing and consulting with internal
team members uh on uh on a a
large a group of qualified nominees
he also has been engaging as you all
know with democrats and republicans and
consulting closely to as a part of the
advice and consent consent part of his
the role of picking uh a nominee uh to
move forward after last week's meeting
with uh chairman dermott and ranking
member grassley the president and vice
president and their senior teams
including white house uh council daniel
dana rimas have also spoken to the range
of additional members of congress and
outside legal experts and that
engagement will continue there is of
course a vetting process that takes
place we have not outlined that in
detail from here
and of course we will venture to be as
transparent as possible even as we are
working to protect uh the process as the
president's making his decision go ahead
thanks jen um with the meeting today
between the president and the german
chancellor does the president view
germany as a reliable partner on this
issue when it comes to troop movements
or sending weapons to ukraine or
talking publicly about sanctions they've
been much less aggressive than other
nato allies well i'd also note that
germany is the second largest donor to
ukraine and europe uh the president has
also noted as we have noted that uh
different countries make different
contributions i think that the
chancellor also did an interview with
the washington post this morning where
he spoke to that in more detail
we have a close abiding important
relationship with the germans that
includes having forces stationed in
germany which has a huge strategic value
to the united states so
today is an opportunity for the
president to build on the relationship
with uh with the chancellor to continue
to build on the long and abiding
relationship with the germans and uh we
are united in our uh view of the actions
uh the potential actions of russian
leaders and united in our efforts to
hold them accountable what's your
understanding
about where the chancellor stands right
now when it comes to including nordstrom
2 in potential sanctions if russia
invades they've really danced around
that issue and haven't given a clear
answer about whether they would in fact
be willing to put that pipeline on hold
well i know you all have the opportunity
i'm sure ask him this question himself
and i of course don't speak for him but
what i can reiterate here is that
we said we'd work with germany to ensure
that nordstrom 2 uh does not move
forward uh should russia invade uh and
that remains the position a great
position uh emmanuel macron's meeting
with
governor president putin today and
chancellor schultz will be meeting with
him in the coming weeks so uh has
president biden asked either of them to
deliver a message to putin when they
meet with him
well i think it's important to remember
that there are a range of different
diplomatic talks happening at the same
time through different formats some are
leader to leader uh some are through
nato some are through the osce and this
is reflective of that these these
conversations that are happening as you
know the president spoke with president
macron yesterday
and of course that close uh discussion
and coordination with a range of leaders
is part of how we're approaching this
but this is uh multi-layered diplomacy
at work here so and we are also directly
in touch with the russians ourselves so
i wouldn't i wouldn't look at it through
that prison
thanks jen um you guys are
sending a background call that
part of the discussion with germany
today was about continuing to prepare
this robust sanctions package but we've
been talking about sanctions for months
so if
germany is as aligned with its allies as
you all are conveying why isn't this
sanctions package already complete why
isn't that done already
in terms of figuring out what it looks
like our internal sanctions package or
what sanctions because you've said
consistently that the sanctions that
you're preparing are in close
consultation with allies including
germany
and that conversation is you know
obviously happening again today
as we're getting warnings that russia
could at any moment take significant
action so the discussion about sanctions
has been over the course of several
months
why isn't it done yet if germany is as
on board
with the rest of the the nato alliance
as
they're projecting to be sure well
jackie i mean as we've said before one i
think there is alignment that uh we will
work with germany to ensure that
nordstrom 2 uh does not move forward
which is obviously a key
a key point of discussion i'd also note
just and reiterate that it's not
operational at this time there's no oil
flowing through the pipeline that has
been a key point of discussion and that
has agreed to uh i would also reiterate
what we've said in here in the past is
that while we have our own sanctions
package prepared which we've been
consulting with and briefing members of
congress on
and others do and we're united in the
effort to put forward in
an economic sanctions package that has
significant consequences as as our
european partners it doesn't mean it's
identical
so
one point clarify you said um
that that is agreed to on nordstrom 2.
are you just want to clarify the germans
have are you saying that the germans
have committed not to bring nordstrom 2
online if russia invades well again i'm
not going to get into the private
diplomatic conversations but it uh we
have re we have said a number of times
that if they invade it will not move
forward
um and then i wanted to ask about dr
lander again um i know you got a
question on this earlier but does the
fact that dr linder has a job still
cheap in the president's promise to fire
anyone who treats colleagues with
disrespect on spot well again i would
just reiterate that the president takes
his commitment to having a respectful
work environment incredibly seriously
and it's something that he conveys
clearly to all of us on a regular basis
that is why we put in place in part put
in place a a safe and respectful
workplace policy which is how which is
on which is the um process through which
this is this thorough investigation
proceeded through uh and the process
through which uh again that there was an
internal investigation uh dr lander
obviously uh his behavior was
inappropriate and corrective actions
needed to be taken and that was clearly
conveyed through this process and he
will be uh held to account for uh for uh
for delivering on that real quick one
third topic um
we've got announcements that in delaware
and new jersey uh the governors are
going to be ending mass mandates coming
up pretty soon
um what is the white house view on these
kinds of announcements given that in
virginia governor younkin faced a lot of
pushback from democrats for making
similar changes to the mass
policy well they weren't actually that
similar because what happened here in
new jersey and uh and a couple of other
states you mentioned is that they pulled
back the requirement they didn't make it
more difficult for schools school
administrators local officials to keep
requirements that they made a
determination would keep their schools
safe
go ahead do you expect that president
macron and president biden will have a
follow-up conversation so that he can
relay
any
sort of impressions that he got from his
face-to-face meeting and would you
commit to letting us know if that
conversation happens
we certainly would on the latter i would
say that as you know the president spoke
with president macron just yesterday
again there's multi multi layers of
diplomacy happening at many times
sometimes those readouts happen at the
secretary of state level or national
security advisor but i can assure you we
are in close contact with the french of
course the germans and all of our nato
partners and allies at the pentagon john
kirby has talked about the possibility
of additional u.s forces being
moved to europe has the president
requested any additional recommendations
from secretary austin is he reviewing
any other plans along those lines
i would just say that we are in constant
contact of course with the defense
department but also with our nato
partners about what their needs are so i
don't have anything to predict for you
other than to reiterate what was said
last week which is that we leave the
door open to that possibility that's an
active possibility at this point it
always has been and i would remind
everyone that there are thousands of
troops that are on the in eastern
european countries as a part of our nato
alliance uh so this is to bolster up the
troops that are already there
good back on the mass mandate question
in new jersey in other states the cdc is
still recommending universal masking in
schools that's correct and that still
remains our recommendation so are you
pleased with it fine with the new jersey
governor's decision
again our advice to every school
district is to abide by public health
guidelines it continues to be at this
point that the cdc is advising that
masks can delay reduce transmission
there are also a number of other
mitigation measures that we've put in
place but that continues to be cdc
guidance it's always been up to local
school districts to determine how they
implement
what does it say then that a governor
like phil murphy who's been so closely
aligned with the policies of this
administration would get ahead of the
medical experts and say
never mind what they say school
districts you decide
well it's always been up to school
districts that's always been our point
of view and always been our policy from
here
and our policy from the federal
government is to continue to advise
everybody to abide by public health
guidelines do you think they'd signaled
that perhaps the public believes it's
time for a change in the federal
guidelines the cdc's got
we certainly understand and have seen in
polling that the public is tired of
covet we understand that so are we and
there has been some good signs recently
where there has been a decrease in
hospitalizations around the country uh
and again we're in constant touch about
uh about what it looks like moving
forward but our responsibility as the
federal government is to rely on the
data and the science uh that is uh being
analyzed by our public health experts
and we'll continue to rely on that for
what recommendations we're making
good yeah a couple things uh so we
reported that u.s officials are losing
patience with the chinese negotiations
about and fulfilling their uh purchase
commitments under the phase one trade
deal signed by donald trump
uh what is the perspective from the
white house in terms of what can you do
and does the president intend to weigh
in on this issue
well it's a good question on andrea i
mean we as you know they did not abide
by their purchase agreements we know
that factually we've seen that uh this
is really under the purview of the ustr
and our trade representative catherine
tai we remain in close touch uh with her
about that but i would really point to
them for any updates on the process okay
and then uh this situation in the
canadians or in ottawa the truckers
protest there does seem to be evidence
that
these uh
truckers are getting support from
conservative forces or regular forces in
the u.s um are you investigating that at
all is there any kind of you know
involvement of u.s authorities and
looking at those money flows going to
these truckers and are you concerned
about it
well uh i would say a couple of things
this doesn't answer your question but i
just want to get this out there too on
this particular topic and then i'll come
around i promise um
we have uh been engaged
since the outset well some of it
hopefully answers your question i should
say of the protests there have been zero
impacts to cbp operations which is a
question people have understandably been
asking us some some shipments were
rerouted by our law enforcement partners
to other points of entry due to road
closures some shippers have had to
reroute but cbp has been in
communication uh throughout to ensure
shipments can be cleared and onto the
normal routes in terms of an assessment
of any other engagement um from here uh
we have we we don't really have any
update on that uh or any any
investigation to read out at this point
in time and then you know in
the federal
federal reserve nominees have run into a
little bit of criticism from
the republicans in particular sarah
raskin
are you
concerned that you're
i mean especially given the absence of
senator lujan are you concerned that you
might not get all those nominees through
and that you may have to withdraw sarah
rusk and there's been another dust up
overnight
she is one of the most if not the most
qualified person to ever be nominated to
this position uh she just gave extensive
answers at a hearing last week and she
would be someone the president would be
proud to have in that role as
independent as it may be so no that is
not an assessment or prediction we're
making go ahead jen two questions for
you one the secretary general of nato
has recently talked about the
possibility of a more permanent military
presence in europe in response to russia
where does the biden administration
stand on that issue we've had a
permanent military presence in europe
you mean in addition a longer term more
permanent uh presence in europe well
we've always had one but you mean a
plused up uh one uh i would really point
the language that was used was longer
term sure well but we've always had one
so it's it's been very long term to date
um but i would say if if if he is asking
and i have not seen his comments about
increased plused up presence and some of
the places from u.s troops that we've
had i would really appoint you the
department of defense obviously we would
we would be in touch with our nato
allies and partners about that but
that is really uh
related to the uh aggression at the
border that we're seeing in ukraine but
there's been tens of thousands of troops
in europe for some time now and just on
the topic of mapping in schools um if
you could just clarify you know you've
talked about this a little bit already
do you think that at some point in the
future even if that point isn't now
it would be appropriate for there to be
updated federal guidelines just to avoid
confusion i think the administration has
been clear that on other issues there
are sort of messaging issues that could
have been a little bit more clear coming
from the administration so on this issue
do you think that that might be
appropriate well the guidance is very
clear which is that we recommend uh
masking in schools that is the
recommendation from the cdc it is also
true that at some point when the science
and the data warrants of course our our
hope is that that's no longer the
recommendation and they are continually
assessing that but the guidance is very
clear it is also true that has always
been up to local school districts to
make determinations about how to
implement these policies
go ahead thanks jen uh just to follow on
that you have said that you guys are in
constant contact
with cdc about what it looks like to
move forward
uh can we expect the president to
provide some sort of robot for how
states can transition out of a state of
emergency kind of akin to what he did
with the winner strategy
we're in constant discussion internally
about the moment we're in as it relates
to kovid and of course uh as the
president said i think during his press
conference just two weeks ago a week and
a half ago um you know we we certainly
don't see this moment now as the new
normal right and we but we want to get
to a point uh where we are not where
covet is not disrupting our daily lives
and i'm sure you will hear more from the
president about that but that's uh we're
constantly discussing that internally
okay one more just for a colleague um
the education department announced
friday was going to withdraw its appeal
for a hundred thousand dollar student
loan forgiveness court decision
wondering if you could shed any light on
why the
administration reversed its decision to
appeal the case and if there's any plans
to fight other bankruptcy cases i i
would really point you to the department
of education department of justice
potentially but i will check and see if
there's anything more we can offer on
that from here good got one more on mass
um i just i was wondering if i could
just ask it this way sure the
president's wife is an educator he just
heard from governors across the country
last week many of whom were saying this
is enough it's time for me normal where
is he on this after taking all of these
inputs well the president is not a
private citizen he's president of the
united states right so his and so i'm
asking well but i guess i'm saying it's
different than than asking kind of a
person on the street right i mean i'm
just you know it is different because he
is the president he needs to project uh
the what the data and the science is
telling us and the data and science
where we get that guidance from is the
cdc and our health and medical experts
their guidance remains continues to be
that that in schools people should mask
up so that is what we are continuing to
convey and recommend and then can you
tell us any more about where he will be
going on thursday
not quite yet but hopefully maybe by the
end of the day we hope to have some more
details very soon
sure go ahead thanks jan um going back
to dr landor
the investigation found credible
evidence of multiple women having
complained to other staff about negative
interactions with him with a pattern of
abuse and disrespectful behavior
again the president
at the outset of this administration
said i will fire you on the spot on the
spot no ifs ands or buts so why is he
not being fired well matt let me first
say that no one is suggesting that this
behavior is acceptable quite the
opposite and that since he's he made the
comment he did which i think was one of
the first few days in office if i
remember correctly we put in place this
safe and respectful workforce policy to
ensure there was a mechanism right to
conduct investigations as was conducted
in this case
that can be thorough that results in
some actions and some steps that's
exactly what happened here but again
this is not acceptable behavior dr
lander is expected to comply
and he will be monitored for compliance
uh because having a safe workplace
environment is imperative to the
president the vice president the first
lady uh the second gentleman all of us
who work here
are there ways in which he's being held
to account if he's not being fired
well again as i outlined a little bit
earlier but let me reiterate a little
bit in addition to a full thorough
investigation uh he was it was conveyed
through meetings with senior white house
officials directly that his behavior was
inappropriate corrective action was
needed and we will monitor for
compliance to that to those actions that
were required again i think you may have
also seen or it was reported
that he also sent a note
to his staff conveying his commitment to
abiding by that and we certainly hope
that that is the case
it doesn't sound like a zero tolerance
policy if that's the case well our
objective and the president's objective
is to prevent this behavior from ever
happening again
thanks jen uh on the supreme court sure
i just i wanted to ask about the
president's efforts to engage with
republicans sure um and whether that's
the best use of this time considering
what he has said about the public not
wanting him to be the president senator
that is true and i think he has he has
not been the president senator over the
course of the last period of time um
it's also true that he takes his role uh
as president um and uh and and going
going through the process of of
selecting and nominating an eminently
qualified nominee very seriously and in
his experience as the former chairman of
the judiciary community committee that
includes consultation with
key members of the senate and that is an
important part of the process in this
case i think what he was referring to in
those comments was
hours and hours and hours of endless
closed-door meetings
as it related to negotiating through the
course of the fall but uh this is a
opening to a lifetime appointment an
opening on the supreme court which a
lifetime appointment something the
president takes very seriously and
consulting with republicans and
democrats is an important part of that
process in his view
i'm
you have you've made clear of the
administration's position i did want to
understand though is the administration
ready to take some type of action
without germany um
to stop north stream too
i understand your question i just am not
in a position to detail further other
than to convey that i will not move
forward of russian invades on dr lander
if i may sure can can you talk about
what some of the specific uh corrective
changes that were ordered what some of
those were and also has the president
spoken with dr lander since uh the
investigation was completed and um does
he worry about this overshadowing mutual
well um
i would say that the president's hope
all of our hope is certainly that dr
lander will abide by making changes that
he will be held
to account
to to comply fully with the steps that
needed to be taken i can see if there's
more specific details i certainly
understand why you're asking
but overall it's ensuring that he's
creating a work environment that people
feel safe they feel supported
and that is respectful and that is the
overarching
policy that needs to be implemented
moving forward you saw him send a note
to staff last week now it is whether he
is implementing those policies moving
forward
i don't have any conversations between
them to read out uh go ahead thanks just
following up on a question asked earlier
about
what you said isn't a split between
ukraine's messaging and your guys's
messaging on the risk of an invasion
can you walk us through the
communication strategy
like what what you're trying to
highlight the risk of invasion and why
you're trying to highlight it more
strongly than ukraine do you see it as
you know sounding me a lot more vocally
is there an advantage that you see and
sort of preventing putin from taking any
further steps here
yeah it's a good question and i can't i
can't speak for the communication
strategy of ukrainians only only they
can speak to that um but i can tell you
that uh what we have been uh trying to
do we obviously have um a a range of
information a broad broad range of
information that
we have been able to gather um here
and also through partnership with our
our allies across the country our
objective as we talked about a little
bit on friday is to deny russia the
opportunity to use
some of the tactics sometimes some of
the lies that they have done in the past
to justify an invasion
of ukraine that's straight out of their
playbook we have seen tactics they have
used in the past where a few years ago
russia's defense ministry falsely
accused the united states of running a
clandestine biological weapons lab in
the country of georgia enabling them
their efforts to destabilize the
georgian government they used to
fabricate stories in syria about how
attacks on international aid convoys
were undertaken by rebels or terrorists
we've so we have undertaken an effort to
in some cases declassify information in
other cases describe in as great a
detail as we can without uh putting at
risk sources and methods what we're
seeing what information we're evaluating
so that they are it is it makes it more
difficult for them to lay a predicate
for invading ukraine so that is uh that
is why we're doing it i'd also note that
a number of your news organizations of
course have reporters near there who are
seeing the troop buildup right so there
is justification and validation from
even that but also from our partners
around the world as well
good
thank you jen senator manchin expressed
confidence over the weekend that reforms
of electoral account act will pass
would the president be supportive of
signing performance electoral accounts
if they were to pass or would he require
that there be elements of the voting
rights bill included in order to do so
well i would really point you to senator
klobuchar who is really one of the point
people leading this effort obviously we
have said many times that the electoral
electoral count act while we support the
effort
is not a replacement for voting rights
legislation for a range of reasons i
know there's a lot of discussions on the
hill about what that may look like or
what a final package i can't outline
that from here
china used a young uyghur athlete to
carry the olympic torch during the
opening ceremony of the games in beijing
what did the administration make of that
given the ongoing genocide against
speakers
well i know that our u.n ambassador
linda thomas greenfield spoke to this
yesterday so let me reiterate what i
thought were some very
powerful comments if i'm remembering i
know someone spoke to it but i believe
it was her um that we can't allow this
to be a distraction um
from exactly as you said uh the human
rights abuses the genocide that we're
seeing in parts of china that is why we
did not send a diplomatic delegation
even as we're cheering for our u.s
athletes diplomacy is complicated as we
know uh but we can't allow it to be a
distraction from what we know is
happening to many people
in china go ahead
just to reiterate on inauguration day
president biden said he would fire
anyone that treat another colleague
disrespect talk down to someone
and they would fire them on the spot no
ifs ands or buts so what is the white
house's message to people that work in
this building and throughout the federal
government that took the president at
his word and don't understand why dr
lander has not been fired our message
and thank you for your question is that
um the president has crystal clear
expectations with all of us about how we
are to treat our colleagues treat people
who work for us um and that is what he
expects for people across the building
it is because of those comments that he
made early on uh in part uh that we put
in place a safe and respectful workplace
policy that was the mechanism for which
this thorough investigation went forward
uh and it also it is based on that uh
that their investigation from that came
the meeting that dr lander had with
senior white house officials where it
was made clear what steps he was
required to take
and that we will be complying and
watching for compliance with those steps
and our objective is of course to
prevent um any of this behavior from
happening again in the future that's the
overarching objective comments those
were a promise absolutely that's why he
we put in place a policy to ensure there
is a mechanism for investigating and a
mechanism for preventing this type of
behavior from repeating itself
the fire people that did this that did
this and he hasn't fired the individual
the white house found
violated what he said
i understand it and again let me just
reiterate nothing about his behavior is
acceptable to anyone here at all quite
the opposite let me be clear about that
but there is now a process in place that
was not in place at the time to evaluate
and determine what the next step the
steps should be taken in the event that
any behavior like this occurs to prevent
it from happening in the future that is
exactly what happened in this case
our employees shouldn't expect that
people will be fired if they treat
colleagues with disrespect again i think
i've outlined very clearly what the
process was go ahead
questions two questions for you excuse
me
it's more it's more than that i think
it's clear that we are putting in place
we put in place a process an internal
process to ensure that there was a
thorough investigation that that the uh
that it was evaluated that steps were
taken for this individual dr lander to
meet with senior officials to make clear
that there were requirements that would
work would be put in place and he was
expected to comply with them to prevent
this behavior from ever happening again
go ahead questions first on senator
manchin on buildback better he
reiterated again his view that that
structure is is is done
um and he said he wants regular order
for any pieces of that little mover that
means potentially we experience all that
um is the president on board with that
idea of hearings markups and is if not
what's his plan for elements of
buildback better to move forward
well uh
i can't speak for senator manchin no no
you're not asking me to but uh what
there is broad agreement on and support
for is taking steps to lower costs for
the american people whether it's
medicare or whether it's ability to
negotiate the price of prescription
drugs something broadly supported
whether it's lowering the cost of child
care elder care
isn't fair in terms of mechanisms and
legislative process i just don't have
any more predictions for you in terms of
how it will proceed
a positive report on friday by and large
however black unemployment is still
twice the rate of white unemployment
what is the white house doing what do
the what does the white house think
needs to be done to deal with that
especially for black men well i would
say just is is a reminder that there's
still as much as the president oversaw
the largest creation of job creation
ever in one year in american history it
means there's more work to be done
because there are still a lot of work
that needs to be done to label level the
playing field to ensure that small
businesses
have the assistance they need including
black owned small businesses that we are
doing everything we can to ensure there
is opportunity uh for a range of parts
of of the economic uh world go ahead
a few on the supreme court yeah
congressman clyburn says that the
president will need bipartisan support
for his supreme court pick citing
senator lujan's stroke and
hospitalization is it the white house's
position that republican votes would be
helpful in the senate or do you view
them as necessary
well
we've i think conveyed from here that we
haven't set a deadline for when a vote
should be we have said we want it to
happen as expeditiously as possible we
have also said and i'll reiterate that
because the president has every
intention of nominating an eminently
qualified uh black woman to serve on the
supreme court that this is a person who
should warrant bipartisan support and
that is certainly what we hope for
speaking of the timeline the president
has said that he intends to make that
announcement by the end of the month has
that timeline shifted in any way mikey
made this announcement before presidents
day weekend i don't have anything uh
february's february so i don't have
anything to predict for you in terms of
when in february quite at this point it
will be go ahead yeah if you don't mind
as far as where and when he could meet
with the uh potential nominees he's
going to camp david this weekend
is the president going to meet with
potential supreme court justices at camp
david this weekend i don't have anything
for you on the process of how the
president will interview nominee
potential candidates go ahead does the
white house have reaction to the death
of the navy seal candidate who died
after completing what's known as hell
week and has the president spoken to his
family or does he have plans to uh i
don't know not not not yet karen i will
we will check and see where that is at
this point obviously there'll be an
investigation here i'd point you to the
department of defense for any specifics
uh as a as a as a starting point here
obviously our heart goes out to the
family members the community uh the
friends uh and we look we'll look for
more details to come out of an
investigation would there be any thought
given to re-examining that training yes
it's a good question i would really
point to the department of defense and
the president would certainly look to
his defense department and leadership to
make any recommendations in that regard
good thanks jen two questions first on
the olympics does the white house agree
with speaker nancy pelosi that american
athletes shouldn't speak out against
beijing for their own safety
well um
i know we saw those comments obviously i
think they were last week if i remember
it correctly um the president's view is
that first we support our athletes a
hundred percent okay um all athletes
have the right uh to freely express
themselves um that is the case in
beijing at the olympics it is the case
anywhere they will make those choices as
individuals uh it's the responsibility
of china to live up to its own
obligations to maintain a safe
environment for all athletes at these
games the world will be watching but we
leave it up to individuals we certainly
support the right to peaceful protest
i'm i'm wondering kind of what was the
thought about having her give that
message is the white house trying to
restart negotiations on buildback better
was there some sort of underlying intent
to have the first lady come out and say
about this one i think it was speaking
uh from her heart about her view that a
free community college would benefit um
kids young people level the playing
field across the country it's something
the president agrees with i think you
all have seen many many iterations of
the build back better legislation
or options in recent months it hasn't
been in there in a while so i think it
was speaking she was speaking from her
heart about
how beneficial she thinks that funding
and that support would be
jen uh two topics one
uh
recently a black man was killed in
minnesota or no not born has the white
house taken note of this
and does this bring a fresh
the renewed call for this executive
order this police reform executive order
as well as the standalone pieces
uh that are potentials on police reform
and capitalism
absolutely and it should um let me
reiterate because i asked a little bit
about this this morning as well um
so
one let me first say that we mourn the
tragic death of emir locke and our
thoughts and prayers are with his family
the president's committed to ensuring
fair and partial and effective policing
and keeping our communities safe these
goals go hand in hand and are in his
view with with what we can achieve by
building trust between the police and
communities they serve so back in
september
attorney general garland issued a new
policy improving imposing restrictions
on the use of no knock warrants
chokeholds and parroted
restraints by federal agents obviously
that's for federal agents so that's
limited not to local but yeah i know you
follow this closely but for others uh
president biden the reason he has been
such a strong supporter one of the
reasons of the george floyd justice and
policing act is that would further
restrict the use of no knock warrants
across the country incentivizing funding
by using funding as an incentive
we
have been engaging with as you know
civil rights groups number of law
enforcement groups all agree on the need
to reform the use of no knock warrants
that is there's a lot of agreement on
that to keep both citizens and law
enforcement officers safe and the
president is examining the possibility
of extending those restrictions to other
federal agencies through actions
executive actions that he would have the
power to do i think you all saw susan
rice convey last week that we're not
there yet we want to make sure we do
any action through the administration
the right way and it's thorough but
certainly that's part of what's being
looked at
and on the second topic
um there is a serious shroud of secrecy
around the nominees of the supreme court
understandably
and i've got two questions on this one
what's traditional about the process
and then what is very unique to the
process because of the historical nature
if you can tell us i'm sure you can give
us something no no it's a good question
it's a very thoughtful question i was
just trying to
um
there you go i i walked right into that
one um i walked right into that one
what i think is um
unique in this moment
is that the president
is someone who has served as the
chairman of the senate judiciary
committee as the vice president when
there were a number of nominees historic
many historic a number of historic
nominees who were nominated and
confirmed by the senate and he takes uh
the process and the seriousness the need
for it to be thorough uh
he's very focused on it um you know i
don't know that that's unique obviously
every president i would hope takes the
process seriously but he also takes as
is there was a question earlier about
this the component about advice uh part
of it very seriously in terms of
consulting with
republicans and democrats in the process
um you know what is unique about this
moment um
you know i want to read your article
about this to hear what you have to say
okay
your next article about it um
you know i think it's safe to say that
there are some criticisms that
have been out there without any names
being confirmed that are unique uh to um
uh to having uh the possibility the
likelihood the plan for a woman of color
being nominated for this position and uh
the types of language that are used by
some uh to describe um who who the
president might pick as a nominee are
unique to to that and you just spoke a
moment ago about advice on his nominees
we know the internal advice particularly
from the council's office as well as the
vice president yeah but external when is
the last time the president talked to me
to help
to anita hill yes uh i would have to
check on that for you april
part of this process because we know
there are
we know that he talked and they had a
very
real conversation
before he
you know became president-elect sure
is she i want to know one is that he can
when is the last time he consulted with
her and if she is part because the names
of those
who are on the outside are dribbling out
and is she one of those and he respects
her opinion i i will check with our team
who are overseeing the process and you
you're familiar with who that internal
team is i know we probably have to wrap
up soon here go ahead
two things on um gas prices um so
president biden has said uh with oil
prices that he released the strategic
petroleum reserves and that brought down
prices actually on that day the price of
oil actually rose and it went down for
the omicron variant um as the fears of
lockdown today oil prices are 91 more
than 91 dollars a barrel
is there any consideration in the
administration reversing any of the
policies or regulations or removing some
to to encourage more drilling in the us
for future demand
well let me tell you what we are doing
of course we of course tap the strategic
petroleum reserve sometimes that takes
some time to to uh to be digested into
the system we've also worked with a
number of countries around the world to
do something similar we've been engaged
with opec nation countries about the
need for the
supply available to meet the demand
we've also called out uh the record
profits made by oil companies uh which
should not be lost uh as an issue as
consumers are looking at the price that
they are paying uh at the the the prices
they are paying and i would also note
that you should check with oil companies
and whether they are tapping into uh all
of the land leases they have available
at their disposal i don't believe they
are what about encouraging the
investment in drilling in other places
in the us
again i think the president's view is
that we
are it is a huge advantage to us to be a
leader in the clean energy transition
and over the course of years and decades
we've become a clean energy superpower
because ultimately that's not just where
the jobs are it's where the strategic
advantage will lie in 10 20 30 years i
would note again and you can ask the oil
companies this there is land they're not
all drilling on every lease is not used
i'd encourage them you to ask them that
question go ahead
if the process does the president know
the german position before the talks in
the oval office speaking
well again i'm sure this will be a part
of the discussion i would bet someone
will ask about this when we're having a
press conference and just a little bit
here but what i can just reiterate is
that it will not move forward
great question to president marcos
visited
moscow today in the minsky creek what is
the white house's position on the
question of autonomy or more autonomy
for the different regions in ukraine for
instance the donbass with the majority
russian population should they have an
increased say in ukrainian national
politics including the question
of which
alliance ukraine want to be a member of
again our position on this has not
changed obviously uh the the minsk
agreements is part of the discussion as
has been reported between president
putin and president macron we'll wait
for those discussions to conclude and we
certainly support any means of
diplomatic engagement all right thanks
everyone
i have enough water in here for
everybody it's so hard
you